I was thinking of adding B propolis to my supplements as I've learned that it has anti-cancer properties.
I found it from a family owned farm in Mississippi and it's and it suggests you take 500 milligrams
one to three times a day. Your thoughts please. Thank you. So B propolis can have a good immune
stimulating property. I actually take some B pollen not every day but at least a couple times a
week to help with allergies. It can be an immune regulator so it helps balance the immune system.
It can be really good for autoimmune issues because of its immune regulation property.
So it can that can be it can have good properties. There's a lot of things. Anything that's
going to be an immune regulator or an immune stimulator is going to have cancer killing properties.
It really isn't much downside to taking it. It's very natural. It's water soluble. It will flush out
of your system. It's not going to overload your liver so there's nothing wrong with taking B propolis.
You can't get it in a liquid form to spray as a spray as well. There's thoughts of different forms